In Don’t Breathe, the main trio is able
to break into houses very easily, because
Alex’s dad owns a security company, and
he’s able to borrow the keys and disarm
their security systems with the click of a
button.
This concept is one of many similarities to
the 2002 film Panic Room, where the character
Burnham is an employee of the house’s security
company and knows all of its weak points.
I’ll get into all the homages to Panic Room
later in this video, but for now, let me focus
on the name of the security company: Liminal
Home Security.
The word: Liminal is derived from the Latin
word “līmen”, meaning “a threshold”.
Simply put, the burglars have to break a threshold,
such as a door window to get into the house.
But there is a different definition; the word
is sometimes used to refer to visual stimuli.
In that definition, liminal relates to a sensory
threshold, as something barely perceptible
or capable of eliciting a response.
For example, thieves silently moving around
a blind man’s house will not warrant a visual
response.
However, as we know there are other senses
that might help such a man detect an intrusion,
as we see in this movie.
No pun intended.
To learn the hidden meaning behind the code
to the blind man’s safe, stick around to
the end of this video.
[INTRO]
I love how the Spanish title of this movie
is just “No Respires”.
“No respires.”
I don’t know why that’s funny to me.
Welcome to Things You Missed.
You know I’m excited for this one.
Cause I’m excited any time I get to go revisit
that perfect year of 2016.
Especially considering… the more recent
years.
- "Ewwwww....."
- [ZAC] Don’t Breathe was the sophomore film of
director Fede Álvarez, and he would bring
back Jane Levy, the lead from his first movie,
the Evil Dead remake.
Like another director of a 2016 horror movie,
Álvarez got his start with a popular short
film on YouTube.
He showcased his technical skill in Ataque
de Pánico! in 2009, and before long he was
on the phone with Sam Raimi and making The
Evil Dead and Don’t Breathe.
However, his next Hollywood boss also seems
to have been an influence on his second movie.
Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
[THINGS YOU MISSED]
The opening shot of the movie shows a scene
from later on in the story, where Rocky is
being dragged back into the house by The Blind
Man.
I had to double check that this was actually
her, because we later find out that she was
not the first woman to be kidnapped by him.
But chronologically, the first characters
we meet are the trio of burglars.
There’s Money, who has a money tattoo, because…
he likes money; Rocky, the struggling young
mom; and Alex, the son of the security system
man.
Despite these three filling the Sly Cooper
archetypes of The Brawn, The Brains and The
Thief, they are more of an homage to another
Band of Thieves: Junior, Burnham and Raoul
from the movie Panic Room.
Tap here for the Things You Missed episode
on Panic Room if you haven’t seen it.
As I mentioned earlier, there are a lot of
similarities to Panic Room, and I do have
a reason for using the word “homage” rather
than the words: “rip-off”.
Fede Álvarez’s next movie after Don’t
Breathe would be The Girl in the Spider’s
Web, the sequel to The Girl With The Dragon
Tattoo, which was directed by David Fincher,
who also directed Panic Room.
In fact, Fincher was executive producer of
The Girl in the Spider’s Web, so he probably
wouldn’t have hired Álvarez if he felt that
he had ripped him off on his previous movie.
That would be like if I joined Screen Rant.
- "EWWW"
I view it more in tune with how I view Disturbia
as a tribute to Rear Window, or Insidious
as the unofficial remake of Poltergeist.
There are certain things that make it obvious
that Don’t Breathe is a tribute.
Panic Room opens with 3D titles superimposed
on the real world.
Don’t Breathe ends with that.
Rocky in Don’t Breathe has the same hairstyle
as Meg Altman in Panic Room.
Money has the same hairstyle as Junior in
Panic Room, and both have kind of a short
temper.
Both feature thieves who target a specific
house because they know there is money inside.
Both homeowners are perceived as being weak,
but that very weakness ends up making them
stronger.
Both homeowners are attacked with gas.
Both movies have a moment where the burglars
discover there’s actually more money than
they thought.
- [ALEX] “There’s a lot more than 300 grand in
there.
That’s gotta be about a million dollars.”
- [ZAC] Both have burglars who unexpectedly bring
a gun.
Both have a burglar that bails out when things
aren’t as promised.
- [BURNHAM] Not with people here. And not with me.
- [ALEX] I'm so out.
- [ZAC] And both risk their lives to go back and save
a blond, blue-eyed woman.
Everyone in both movies has an interest in
not getting the cops involved.
Both movies show someone getting beat with
a hammer, and both end with a mother and daughter
looking for a new home.
Perhaps the biggest homage though, is the
camerawork.
When I covered Panic Room I talked about the
huge flying one-shot that establishes the
layout of the house, and does what the burglars
cannot, but probably wish they could by passing
through objects, walls and floors.
The one shot in Don’t Breathe is also really
impressive, because it not only establishes
the layout of The Blind Man’s home, but
it also sets up everything that would later
happen in the movie.
As soon as we get in the house we look down
and see them removing their shoes for stealth,
which ends up being how the Blind Man discovers
how many intruders there are, then we look
up at the skylight that Alex would later fall
though, then we push forward into the hammer
that The Blind Man uses to board up the windows
and trap them in, which is also the hammer
that Alex eventually uses to attack him and
save Rocky.
Then Money notices these bells which we later
learn are attached to Cindy, who is The Blind
Man’s basement prisoner and carrier of his
replacement-child.
Then we follow Rocky into the closet where
the safe is hidden, then we brush past the
big lock on the basement door, which suggests
he’s hiding something down there, then Alex
inspects the alarm which would eventually
be used to disorient The Blind Man, then we
go up through the ceiling and briefly pass
through the crawlspace that Rocky would eventually
try to escape through, then we go into the
man’s room where he’s falling asleep to
the sound of a home video of his daughter,
suggesting that he hasn’t dealt with her
death in a healthy way at all and may have
other questionable coping mechanisms which
may or may not be hidden in that basement,
then we dive under his bed and see where his
gun is hidden, which he would later use to
come after them -- before finally we see him
and Money entering his room to gas him out.
That is all one shot, and it sets up every
other scene that takes place in the house.
It’s also a big reason that this scare a
moment later, is so impactful, even though
he’s just sitting there, because we’ve
just been through three minutes and sixteen
seconds without a cut, and we’re not really
expecting one anymore.
There are other potential foreshadowing moments,
and one secret that you need to see THIS deleted to scene to fully understand.
[🎵 upbeat mysterious  music]
At the first house they break into, Alex starts
by grabbing a pair of headphones, perhaps
a clue that sound plays a huge role in this
movie.
He also grabs a book -- Fool’s Gold by Dolores
Hitchens, a 1958 novel about two teen delinquents
and a girl who try to rob a house that looks
like it’s going to be an easy job, but they
find themselves in trouble after getting wrapped
up with some older, more experienced thieves.
There is a movie adaptation of Fool’s Gold,
a French picture called Band of Outsiders.
And thanks to my French New Wave class in
college, I have seen it.
There’s a scene in that movie where the
characters are dancing to music from a jukebox
at a restaurant.
[🎵 1950s Rock and Roll]
Don’t Breathe actually has a deleted scene
where Rocky steals a waitresses tip and her
and Alex start dancing to cover it up, and
they discuss the ethics of their next job.
Low and behold, the song on the jukebox is
a sped up cover of the song from Band of Outsiders.
[🎵 Rock Music]
- [ALEX] What are you doing?
- [ROCKY] Dancing.
- [ALEX] I mean that.
- Are you kidding? We cleaned up an entire house yesterday.
Anyway, the other book on the shelf next to
Fool’s Gold is called The Light of Day by
Graham Swift.
Just the title alone makes me think of Rocky
escaping into the daylight at the end of the movie.
There’s also a part where Money can be seen
spraying some of his… uhh… cleaning fluids…
onto the floor.
Not a great idea, considering that stuff contains
DNA and this is about to be a crime scene,
but it’s an interesting choice because The
Blind Man happens to have his own freezer
full of “cleaning fluids” hidden down
in his basement to try to pass his own DNA
down to a new generation.
Money is not the only character who… isn’t
the smartest kid.
Rocky’s plan is to steal the money, and
use it to move her and her daughter to California..
- This guy is sitting on at least 300K.
- [ROCKY] If we do this right, we never have to do
it again.
So that’s, what?
$100K each?
That’s not gonna pay the bills for very
long in California.
I think the intention here is to show that
these characters are still dumb teenagers.
It’s kind of like in It Follows, how the
kids come up with this ridiculous plan which
obviously doesn’t work, but it’s still
believe able that they’d be dumb enough
to attempt it.
Also, both movies take place in Detroit, so
there must be something in the water over
there in Michigan.
There are a couple more interesting setups
and instances of foreshadowing early on.
Rocky explains the meaning of her ladybug
tattoo, how her mother used to lock her in
the trunk of her car and a ladybug flew in
through a hole to comfort her.
This may be what gave her the idea to lock
the dog in the trunk when it comes after her
at the end.
They read the article about how The Blind
Man came upon his windfall by reaching a settlement
with the family of his daughter’s killer.
If you look closely you’ll see that the
article is written by Zoltán Berta.
This is an easter egg put in by Zoltán himself,
he’s the motion graphic designer on Don’t
Breathe.
He was also probably responsible for adding
in this date: Sept. 29, 2016.
I remember that day, it’s the day the Cubs
Pirates games ended in a tie, something I
didn’t even know was possible until it happened.
Ultimately, it means nothing for the movie,
but there is another date that is more significant.
The combo to the safe -- both safes actually,
the one in the closet and the one in the basement
is 2978.
According to IMDB, this is the birthday of
director Fede Álvarez, February 9th, 1978.
But besides that there are just so many great
details that make more sense on repeat viewings.
Like how the dog is chained up next to the
basement hatch, and how the movie shows us
that it’s locked, even on the inside.
I guess Money was right about one thing.
- Just cause he’s blind don’t mean he’s
a ****in saint bro.
It’s interesting how The Blind Man’s disability
can actually be an advantage for him.
In this case, Money doesn’t see him as as
much of a threat, causing him not to shoot
when he had the chance, and he gains an advantage
over Alex and Rocky by turning off the lights,
because he’s already used to navigating
the house with no vision.
Side note, I love the look of the scene in
the dark.
The filmmakers effectively communicate darkness
without making the screen black, and without
using any green night vision looking filter.
Very creative scene.
Rocky eventually escapes the house, but after
outwitting The Blind Man’s dog, she’s
captured again, and dragged back inside.
As, she’s laying there, she kind of goes
out of focus, it’s almost like she’s giving
up and her own vision is fading, but this
causes her to see the ladybug which helps
her out again, because when she looks over
at it, she realizes how she can neutralize
her opponent using the alarm.
The tactics they use against each other are
a lot like that chess match I talked about
when discussing Panic Room.
The barrage of sound drives The Blind Man crazy,
and he shoots the gun wildly, accidentally
hitting the mantle photograph of his daughter,
which is symbolic of the fact that his last
chance to carry on his lineage is about to
escape him.
It may not have been his last last chance
though, because there is going to be a sequel.
- ¡No Respires Dos!
- I’ve personally been avoiding the previews
so I can go in blind… pun intended... but
once it’s available I’ll probably be covering
it here on Things You Missed.
So make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications even if you’re not a basement
prisoner, and I’ll see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.
So get vaccinated.
[🎵 Spooky Dance Music]